hey 42 here there are certain things in
life that are universally known there
are eight planets in the solar system
the blue whale is the biggest animal
that ever lived diamond is the hardest
naturally occurring substance on Earth
and Mount Everest is the tallest
mountain
but my dear viewer that fact is a total
lie and if you think this video is just
going to be about a certain Hawaiian
volcano you're only half right what if I
was to tell you that there are in fact
two mountains other than Everest that
can quite confidently claim to be the
tallest on Earth you see despite the
fact that every textbook website
encyclopedia and natural history
documentary you've ever seen has
confidently told you that Mount Everest
is the tallest peak on the planet I've
got some peculiar news for you it isn't
well it probably isn't but let's dig a
Little Deeper shall we surf shark VPN
keeps you safe and private by covering
up everything you do online and
surfsharkvpn lets you travel the world
virtually by changing your virtual
location or if you are physically
traveling surfshark lets you connect via
your home country so you don't miss out
on any of your home Comforts such as
streaming video content from home that
might be blocked whilst traveling there
are over 3 200 servers in 100 countries
so anywhere you go you'll find a server
that fits your needs surfsharkvpn offers
a multi-hub feature so you can put two
VPN servers between you and your online
destination for even more privacy and
security and I love surfshark's IP
Rotator feature which constantly changes
your device's IP address without losing
your VPN connection
it's really important to stay safe
online when out and about and that's why
I use surfsharkvpn so I can for example
access my online banking safely even on
public Wi-Fi there's no chance I'd ever
do that without a VPN quite simply
surfsharkvpn is an essential tool and by
using the Code 42 you'll benefit from an
83 discount plus free extra mums for
free all you have to do is click the
special link in the description below so
don't miss out and thanks to surfshark
for sponsoring this video
in 1802 the East India Company launched
one of the biggest cartographical
projects in history known as the great
trigonometrical survey is aims to
precisely map all four and a half
million square kilometers of the Indian
subcontinent over the course of almost
70 years the great trigonometrical
survey quite literally put India on the
map and one of its crowning achievements
was to determine the exact height of
many of the tallest mountains on Earth
this was only 200 or so years ago just a
few Generations back but in those days
many of these most massive of mountains
were completely unknown to Western
science it wasn't just that we weren't
sure how tall they were we didn't even
know they existed that made the great
trigonometrical survey a true journey of
Discovery and as its cartographers
explorers and surveyors penetrated ever
deeper into the remotest reaches of the
Himalayas they met her a more monstrous
mountains as a result the mountain
considered to be the tallest on Earth
changed on a fairly regular basis
throughout the 19th century as new Peaks
were discovered and accurately measured
for the first time
in their 300 years or so preceding the
survey it had been widely accepted that
Mount Chimborazo in Ecuador was the
tallest mountain in the world when
measured against sea level that changed
in 1808 when the survey discovered a
Nepalese mountain called dolagiri which
wasn't just bigger than Chimborazo it
was much bigger almost two whole
kilometers dalagiri was considered the
tallest mountain on Earth until 1847
when kachin junga was found to be a
couple of hundred meters taller and
catch and junga passed a baton onto K2
when it was discovered in 1856. K2 only
held a record for a matter of months
because later that year Mount Everest
named after George Everest one-time head
of the great trigonometrical survey and
surveyor general of India was officially
declared the tallest mountain in the
world
it's held that title ever since
but despite more than 160 years as the
world's Premier Peak Mount Everest's
hold on that lofty record is
surprisingly shaky
the question is if Everest isn't the
true king of mountains what is
confusingly there isn't actually a
simple answer to that question it all
comes down to how you measure it and
sure enough if you were to hold up the
world's longest tape measure against
every mountain on Earth you would indeed
find that Mount Everest is the tallest
but my friend you just made the Classic
mountain measuring mistake of standing
on dry land
because the honor of highest hill
actually belongs to Mauna Kea a dormant
volcano that Towers over Hawaii the
largest of the Hawaiian islands and
Mauna Kea doesn't just pip Everest by
her hair standing at a staggering 10 210
meters is well over a kilometer taller
if you were to drop Britain's tallest
mountain Ben Nevis directly on top of
Everest's snowy Peak Mauna Kea would
still be bigger there is however a bit
of a catch more than half of the mighty
Mountain Mauna Kea is submerged beneath
the Pacific Ocean leaving a little over
4 200 meters above sea level that's why
Everest is officially considered the
taller mountain and you might think that
sounds perfectly reasonable but is it
really standing at eight feet three
inches Turkish farmer Sultan cousin is
the tallest man alive today if he was to
say stand in a swimming pool for a bit
would that change his height would the
good people at Guinness give his record
to somebody else
obviously not so why doesn't the same
logic apply to mountains
You could argue that to Turkish farmer
going for a dip isn't quite the same as
Mauna Kea standing submerged in the
Pacific Ocean ever since it Formed about
a million years ago and that's a fair
point but not even oceans are permanent
admittedly climbing mountakea is going
to be a very different experience to
scaling Everest you're going to need
access to a submarine for one thing and
in contrast to the rarified air of
Everest's upper slopes the peak of Mauna
Kea isn't even always covered in snow
perhaps that's the real reason Mount
Everest is so widely accepted as Big
Daddy Mauna is clearly taller but
Everest Pierce is higher into the
atmosphere when you reach its peak you
are quite literally Standing On Top of
the World the closest you can get to the
stars with your feet on Solid Ground
except
isn't actually true either we've already
established that Everest isn't the
tallest mountain on Earth if you measure
from base to tip and you should always
measure bass to tip but what if I were
to tell you that you can climb even
higher unless you're Kyrie Irving you
probably picture planet Earth as a giant
sphere that's how it's always depicted
and that's how it appears when we see
images of it from space but that isn't
entirely accurate in reality our home
world is an oblate spheroid to put that
into normal person English Earth isn't
spherical nor is it flat it's fat thanks
to the combined effects of gravity and
Earth's spin like your waistline after
Christmas dinner our planet bulges
around the middle on a planetary scale
that bulge is absolutely tiny if you
were to shrink curve down to the size of
a beach ball it would be about a
millimeter wider when measured around
the equator rather than through the
poles that's why you can't protect the
Bulge when you see images of Earth from
space but on something the size of a
planet even a minuscule deformation such
as this has a significant impact on a
human scale someone standing at the
North Pole is about 20 kilometers closer
to Earth's core than someone standing on
the equator and the same of course is
true for mountains thanks to a boost
from Earth's unsightly punch the highest
point on Earth when measured from the
center of the planet isn't on top of
Mount Everest it isn't even in the
Himalayas it's ten thousand miles away
in Ecuador
I mentioned at the start of this video
that for several hundred years Mount
Chimborazo in Ecuador was forced to be
the tallest mountain in the world when
measured against sea level Mountaineers
today flock to Mount Everest but in the
17th and 18th century it was Chimborazo
that brought in crowds of climbers
hoping to stand on top of the world in
reality back then Western science had
gotten this one quite spectacularly
wrong with an elevation of just 6263
meters Chimborazo doesn't even make the
top 200 tallest mountains on Earth it's
only the 39th tallest in the Andes but
in a genuinely incredible coincidence
thanks to its location just one degree
south of the Equator Chimborazo is the
highest point on the planet its peak is
a healthy
3967 miles from Earth Center a full 1.3
miles higher than the peak of Mount
Everest despite being more than 2.5 km
shorter when measured against sea level
so in the end although 17 found 18th
century Mountaineers who made it to the
peak of Chimborazo really were standing
on top of the world just not in the way
they fought so then Everest Mauna Kea or
Chimborazo
ultimately it's up to you but there's a
very real argument here that of these
three mountains Everest actually has the
least claim to the title of tallest on
Earth Mauna Kea is objectively the
biggest and Chimborazo is undisputedly
the highest by comparison Everest record
as the highest peak above sea level
starts to sound kind of Niche even a
little arbitrary don't get me wrong
Everest remains a majestic and inspiring
place it pierces further into the
atmosphere than any other Mountain
making its peak one of the most extreme
places ever visited by man it has an
incredible history and its status is a
mountain of legendary proportions is so
very well deserved but that doesn't
change the fact that there are many ways
of measuring the most monstrous mountain
on Earth and Everest only wins in one of
them
thanks for watching